j half on the mountain for the twins
he's fastball heavy he's going to throw
a lot of fastballs he likes his fastball
but he's got to stay out of the middle
so good for four innings in cleveland
when all of a sudden he started finding
the inside corner and up and away
driven to right
kepler back still back and makes the
catch right in front of the fence going
away
high fly to right field and kepler comes
in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
scoreless inning for jay ham irvin
santana who makes his second
start this year and the
386th start of his career
there's mondoci with the shift and
kepler's going about 75 percent up the
line
he stays 3-2 pitch line to right center
field that's going to fall for base hit
donaldson did not read that initially
well
still will get to second base
uncontested
and the twins have two on
one out and nelson cruz coming up
that's down the right field line gonna
be a long run for solaire he's not going
to get there here comes donaldson and he
will score and it might be a
history-making run
i believe that josh donaldson has just
scored the 2 millionth run
in major league history
got him oh so even better than a ground
ball
in the air left center field
and wit's out there today so not bad all
things considered minnesota gets one but
they also had second and third and one
out
to center
and ref schneider with the catch
pretty well hit ball for the first out
full count
and
[Applause]
[Music]
to swing it all around the box and the
pitchers are going to throw it in there
deep to center ref schneider going back
on the track ends the inning
trevor larnick
here's a high blast to right center
field and it's not coming back
he put it up from a restaurant again 91
miles an hour and basically just
just north of center cut and that's
going to be a pitch that trevor larnick
is going to make a living on the rest of
his life
after an inning and a half and now max
kepler has come out after trying to beat
out that ground ball
and sono is in at first base with
kiriloff moving out to right field to
replace kepler
to the bag double play nicely done by
polanco
so here's salvi with one on and two out
over the plate and salvi hits it deep to
left field and that ties the game
with another target field home run
slider middle sorry this was bragging on
him how he's missing staying out of the
middle and salvia will let you know nice
shot tenth on the year
royals home monday night and tuesday
night against pittsburgh and there's a
wave and a miss at a slider down and in
and a slider pull to the right side or
to the left side i should say gutierrez
has it he'll make a sidearm flip to
first
off balance a beautiful throw by
gutierrez
and he gets the out what a play
call third strike
another
generous outside corner given by tim
timmons
and there's
strike three and dozier knew it so back
to back strikeouts looking
straight three and half strikes out the
side in the fourth and they're loaded up
with walls there's rest snider with the
bases loaded
that's the short center
and that's going to die for a base hit
red snyder with a little flare into
center field and the twins lead to three
to two bases full of twins now you get
miguel ceneaux who came on for kepler
who left the game
and a fastball is hit very high to right
field dozier gets behind it the catcher
garver is at third dozier makes the
catch and garver hits the brakes
josh donaldson looking for his first hit
this season danny with two outs and
runners in scoring position
and that is to the big stop in here
comes garber to score and it's 4-2
and the 0-2 just want to miss got him
they chased something outside that was a
four-seam fastball
and a better breaking ball got him yeah
good little change-up right there that's
that's some great pitching
that's hit to center
hanging in the air and ref schneider
puts it away good inning for alkaline a
couple of strikeouts and a one two three
six and now larnick homer to center and
drew a walk
that is a fair ball and he gets by
santana
lyric rounds first digging for second
the throw is going to be in time
garber scoring
5-2
where he wanted to where the catcher was
calling for it great breaking ball right
there
tyler duffy
and a breaking ball gets another wave
and a miss and we're starting to see
more and more
of that from tyler duffy a breaking ball
that
teams are chasing once again
there it is on a check swing
pretty impressive inning for duffy three
swinging strikeouts
donaldson
grounds to short he is one for four
that's a good tidbit i like that
kiriloff is down on strikes
monday gets a nice big bounce and cruz
is out and the royals have a first and
third and the tying run is coming to the
plate in wood merrifield
double play grounder
one
and the throw pulls to no no he kept a
foot on the bag a 5-3 ball game and
perez will come up as the tying run sets
up down and away and the 1-2 pitch
ground ball left side twins have polanco
there field sets and throws him out and
that's out number three
high fly right field retreating is
dozier still going back
and that hits the base of the wall
polanco flying around second and he'll
hold up there
first and third one down ref snyder at
the plate
he's lined to third and through base hit
left field ref snyder delivers yet again
rough snyder picks up his second hit
today his second rbi the twins regained
a three-run lead so now it's a three-run
lead and a save situation for taylor
rogers and now monteci single and two
strikeouts on the afternoon
on the c hits it deep to left field in
the corner gone
just like that he had been all over
those those offerings those change-ups
in the middle and just an another easy
effortless swing puts them one closer
and now alberto last hope for the royals
twins territory on their feet the 1-2
pitch he got him alberto strikes out
swinging and the twins win the game six
to five